In the video where I give an
overview of American history
through the Civil War, I
commented that it's unfortunate
that Abraham Lincoln
is assassinated shortly
before the end of the Civil War.
And although that is technically
correct, what I want to do
is clarify that comment a
little bit in this video.
Because in actuality by the
time he was assassinated,
Lincoln knew that the Union
was very, very, very likely
to win the war, that the major
Confederate armies had already
surrendered to the Union.
Although it wasn't
formally done,
there was still
some fighting going
on in some parts of the South.
So if we go back
to April 9, 1865
you have the battle at
Appomattox Courthouse,
and after that battle
the Confederate army
is essentially routed.
It has to surrender.
This right here
is Robert E. Lee.
And on April 9, 1865
after that battle,
he surrenders to
Ulysses S. Grant.
And one point of confusion
some people often have, and I
had this the first
time I learned it,
is that Appomattox Courthouse
is the name of the city,
that the surrender
actually did not take place
in the courthouse in that city.
And I actually shouldn't
even call it a city.
It's like a little town
with a handful of buildings.
It took place in this
gentleman's house,
Wilmer McLean.
And I'm showing
his image because,
his set of circumstances or how
he is tied to the Civil War,
is frankly fascinating.
Because in 1861 the first
battle of the Civil War
occurred on his property
in Manassas, Virginia.
This is in northern Virginia.
He was sympathetic with
the Confederate army.
He did not like that
northern Virginia was
so close to the
North-South border.
So he picks up his
bags and his family,
and he moves them
down to the small town
of Appomattox Courthouse,
which is in central Virginia.
So the very first major
land battle of the Civil War
literally occurs on
this guy's property.
And the last major or
really the major surrender
of the Civil War occurs
inside this guy's house
after he moves.
And it's all coincidence.
He just happens to
have the nicest house
near the battlefield
where everyone
felt that it was appropriate
to have this kind of major end
to a major war.
But regardless, that
happens on April 9, 1865.
The major Confederate army
surrenders to the Union army.
The reason why this is not the
formal end of the Civil War
is that you still had 175,000
Confederate troops other places
in the south
continuing to fight on.
You have to remember
that we didn't
have a telephone at
this point in time,
so we didn't have
instant communication.
So these people who were
fighting, many of them
did not even know that the
Confederate army had already
surrendered to the Union.
But to some degree
this major surrender
is what leads to
Lincoln's assassination.
Because for most
people this tells you,
hey, there's a 99.9% chance
that the Union has won.
It just has to,
either these people
need to find out that their
major army has surrendered,
or the Union has to go
and essentially force
all of the rest of the
armies to surrender.
So you go to April 14, 1865.
Lincoln already knows
that Robert E. Lee's army
has surrendered.
He knows that
victory is imminent.
But you have this gentleman
right over here, John Wilkes
Booth, who is sympathetic
to the Confederate cause.
And in his mind all
is not lost yet.
He does see this as a major
blow to the Confederate cause,
and he thinks that they need
to do something desperate
if they want to have any chance
of being able to come back,
being able to maintain their
independence from the Union.
So he coordinates with
a couple of his buddies.
And he says, hey
our only chance is
if we assassinate not only
Abraham Lincoln, but also
Andrew Johnson who's the vice
president, and Ulysses S Grant,
and we assassinate Seward, who
was the Secretary of State.
And the idea there is if
you assassinate everyone
who is in line to
become president,
then it would just throw
the entire Union leadership
in disarray, and maybe it would
give these characters over here
a fighting chance to
maintain their independence
or maybe come back
against the Union Army.
Unfortunately for
John Wilkes Booth,
or I guess well you
could take it either way,
the other three people were
not able to fully execute
on their plan.
Seward was injured.
He actually did get stabbed
in the face and all that,
but he was not assassinated.
And John Wilkes Booth
was the only person
who was able to carry
out his assassination.
So you have on April 14, 1865
shortly after 10:00 PM Abraham
Lincoln is watching a
play at Ford's Theater.
And his booth, the guy who was
supposed to guard the booth,
was out drinking
with his buddies.
So I guess the Secret
Service really, the security
was not back then what it is
now, hopefully what it is now.
And John Wilkes
Booth, who actually
used to act at this theater,
he picked a time in the play
where everyone would
laugh and clap.
And he said, hey, I'll
just shoot right then.
People will think it's part
of the play or something,
or they wouldn't notice
as much, and then
I'll be able to run out.
And so he is able to, right in
that moment shortly after 10:00
PM, shoot Abraham Lincoln
and assassinate him
on April 14, 1865.
But the whole point here
is to just understand
that Lincoln did know that
Robert E. Lee's army had
surrendered at the time
of his assassination.
So he at least
was feeling pretty
good about the
course of the war.